livres directement sur le marché au
milieu des stands de fruits et légumes
l'ag le coin adultes donc avec les
grands formats l'élu de poche livres
pratiques bandes dessinées romans
graphiques
et ici ça va être du 8 12 ans les romans
8 12 ans et 14 ans et plus avec sa
roulotte l'orif ardoin a entamé un tour
de france l'objectif se rendre là où
l'on ne trouve pas de librairie à
proximité à la base citer les bibliobus
donc des bibliothèques qui se déplace
dans les écoles par exemple
pour aller à la rencontre des enfants et
leur prêter des livres
et donc c'est ça qui m'a donné envie moi
c'est le fait que les librairies ce que
les livres se déplace jusqu'à une usine
jusqu'à nous ici on trouve des livres
bien sûr mais aussi des jeux de société
et des cartes plus de 1400 références au
total de quoi en faire un lieu de rendez
vous sera trouve de conduire
des sables hic
dans les cas oui parce que en inde et
nivelles les habitants de saint paterne
racan sont convaincus dans nos communes
rurales on est éloigné des de la culture
des librairies bien sûr donc cette
initiative
ça a tout de suite marché le premier
jour où elle est venue tout le monde
était content heureux je dirais et la
roulotte se remarque de loin quand je
suis passé de la bae vin est bon et que
j'ai vu ça j'ai dit ça doit être un
marchand livre parce que ce convoyage
des petits livres que je passais la
envoyer des livres et ça faisait très
beau
laurie quittera l'indre et loire à la
fin du mois direction la vendée mais
elle reviendra peut-être y poser ses
valises et sa roulotte une fois le tour
de france terminé